en 2016 2017 de travail
travail et de courtes impulsions
électriques sur une zone précise du
cerveau durant une quinzaine de minutes
cette thérapie permet maintenant un
camée et danube et de soigner les graves
symptômes que pu lui causer sa
dépression saisonnière
j'étais très fatigué j'ai beaucoup de
difficultés de concentration l'anxiété
monte à des niveaux catastrophiques
c'est j'ai difficilement fonctionner le
camp ça quand ça avait vraiment le
traitement et non invasif et cause très
peu d'effets secondaires avec des cimes
des technologies comme la stimulation
magnétique transcrânienne il semble
qu'on vient normalisé l'activité de
grands réseaux neuronaux là pour un peu
le diminuer ont prédit revenir nairas
ténu mais les flammes en moyenne le
traitement s'étend sur six semaines à
raison de plusieurs séances
hebdomadaires
avez vous vu une différence remarquable
au moment où vous avez changé de près
oui oui honnêtement les traitements ici
ça m'a rendu ma vie la stimulation
magnétique transcrânienne est prescrite
de plus en plus fréquemment au chum pour
soigner les cas de dépression sévère ce
qui répond peu ou pas du tout aux
médicaments
son efficacité est démontrée sur 100
patients traités 40% entre en rémission
et 30 % voient leur état s'améliorer il
faut comprendre que l'assignation dtcc
transcranial par exemple ce n'est plus
expérimental il ya quelques années ce
l'était encore mais depuis 2016 et puis
les nouveaux guides à pratiquer sont
sortis serment reconnu comme un
traitement efficace à utiliser en
dépression lorsqu une dépression
résistent aux traitements habituels de
stimulation l'équipe médicale peut avoir
recours à un implant qu'on glisse sous
la peau près de la clavicule du patient
l'appareil stimulait électriquement 1ère
connecter directement son cerveau 24
heures sur 24 peut rythme établi en
fonction de ses besoins spécifiques
l'implant de lise la douceur et mais une
pulsation à toutes les cinq minutes une
batterie un style à part mais au lieu
d'être branché sur l'eau car moi c'est
sûr les narvals tourne en ce moment même
stimulation ma voix change c'est le seul
effet secondaire quand même pour elle
aussi cette approche a fait toute la
différence après quinze ans de
dépression majeure j'avais plus beaucoup
d'espoir la souffrance est un très très
grand qui s'était comme pour moi la
dernière option au québec il y a quatre
cent mille nouveaux cas de dépression
chaque année et on considère que le
tiers sont difficiles à traiter
pourtant seuls trois centres
hospitaliers y quelques cliniques
privées offrent actuellement ce service
bien commencé à avoir un changement dans
l'attitude j'dirais l'or est dans
l'intérêt démontré par nos collègues
qui disent mon bain comment est ce que
je peux offrir ça alors des fois c'est
en nous référant les patients puis quand
après un certain de volumétrie c'est
bien on va développer à l'interné qui on
va vous réserver les coques plus plus
coriace au plus complexes utilisées
couramment aux états unis et en france
ces thérapies fait aussi l'objet de
recherches de pointe depuis quelques
années on plafonne avec la médication
faut quand même dire depuis presque
trente ans on a beaucoup de molécules et
beaucoup de ces molécules qui sont
similaires à ce qui existait déjà avec
mes profil d'effets secondaires plus
intéressant mais vraiment des
révolutions moléculaire il y en a peu et
donc il faut se tourner vers d'autres
options bien sûr il s'agit encore de
traitements alternatifs et qui a ses
limites mais parfois il peut accomplir
de véritables petits miracles les
semaines qui ont suivi les débuts des
traitements j'ai comme j'ai remarqué que
quand je sortait dehors et je voyais le
ciel bleu je ressentais l'espèce de
petites joies que j'avais complètement
perdus avant je me suis mis à prendre
des photos de tous les ciels bleus que
j'étais capable d'attraper quand yves
imbeault nuage pour que ce soit jean les
points sur mon téléphone parce que là
tout d'un coup j'étais renouveau capable
de ressentir de la joie ça m'a fait
vraiment vraiment beaucoup de bien
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal